so have any of you had that moment where
you realize everyone is using some word
and you have no idea what that means but
you're too afraid to ask at this point
what even is machine learning well it's
an approach to making lots of small
decisions with data something involving
algorithmically finding patterns in data
but let me just put it bluntly so that
we can all get it
it's a thing labeler essentially that's
what machine learning is it's just a
thing labeler so why on earth should you
be excited about fing labeling well
here's my pet Huxley and you've just
taken in some pretty complicated data
through your senses and you just know
that that's a cat and if I show you a
different image you're not fooled you
still know that that label is cat your
brain just does this you don't even know
how your brain does it now if we wanted
to get a computer to perform this
labeling task for us if we went the
traditional way you know this
programmers we would communicate with
the universe in some way think really
deeply about the problem and come up
with a model that's a model it's just a
recipe it's a set of instructions that
the computer has to follow to get from
the image to the label and we would have
to handcraft that now think about what
this recipe would have to be for the
computer to correctly detect that
there's a cat in an image I mean think
about what you your brain actually did
with those pixels can you express that
do you know what your brain is doing or
have you just had the benefit of eons of
evolution and it just kind of figures it
out for you now that recipe is really
hard to handcraft wouldn't it be better
if you could just say to the Machine
here look at a bunch of examples of cats
got a bunch of examples of not cats and
just figure it out yourself
that is what machine learning is all
about it is a completely different
programming paradigm now instead of
giving explicit instructions you program
with examples with data and let that
machine learning algorithm figure it out
and stitch that code that goes in
between for you so why should you
actually be excited by this thing
labeling well engineers you know we like
to get computers to do stuff for us and
there's a whole class of tasks where we
just cannot express the instructions
they're ineffable AI and machine
learning are about automating a be
ineffable this is a fundamental leap in
human progress now you can get computers
to do tasks where you cannot possibly
Express the instructions this is so
exciting it seems futuristic and
difficult right and when you think about
machine learning the one thing I most
want you to think about is microwaves
who here in the audience knows how a
microwave oven works well enough to
build a new one from scratch raise hands
who can build a new one do I see any
takers
any takers no hands yeah me neither
who here has never used one to reheat
food you all have even though you have
no idea how it works you're still happy
to use one right and anyone here feel
like you would have no idea how to get
hold of one I don't know like maybe at
Kohl's if you needed one now you've just
told me you have no idea how it works so
how could you possibly trust this
microwave well you're not gonna trust it
by reading the wiring diagram or
you you're gonna trust it by checking
that it actually does work by having a
good idea of what you want it to do for
you and then tasting what comes out on
the other side and that is exactly what
you'll do with machine learning and this
is a perfect analogy for machine
learning now what they don't tell you
about machine learning when we use that
term it's actually two machine learnings
not one two completely different
disciplines that are as different as
building microwaves from scratch and
innovating in the kitchen and you need
completely different skill sets for
these if you don't want to be a machine
learning researcher you are building
general-purpose tools for other people
to use and so the bad news there is that
there is quite a lot of Education that
you need to get takes a little while to
ramp up because how on earth are you
gonna build a better microwave than the
one that exists already there's some
pretty sophisticated stuff out there if
you have no idea how the current one
works so that's the bad news takes a
long time to become a machine learning
researcher the good news though is if
that is your cup of tea we at Google
have a large machine learning research
shop where we make these tools for you
that are all powered by open source so
we give you those wiring diagrams as a
springboard so that you can go and build
a better microwave than what we have
using our blueprints and tend to flow a
really popular machine learning project
started at Google before we open sourced
it because we believe that the community
as a whole so much more innovative than
just anyone of us alone but let's face
it most of you are not here to build
general-purpose microwaves you just want
to get cooking already right you just
want to use these things to solve
business problems and so you are in the
completely other discipline applied
machine learning now for that you do not
need a PhD you don't need to know how
backpropagation works in neural networks
any more than a chef needs to know how a
microwave is wired instead
what you need is a really good kitchen
to play in and we at Google provide that
for you let me show you some of the
things that we have and what you're
gonna need kind of depends on what
you're cooking if you're cooking with
usual ingredients data and you're making
usual dishes labels predictions so say
you're making pizza please don't go
reinvent the concept of pizza from
scratch there's already recipes out
there and you can just grab those
recipes and start making pizza and that
is what our cloud api's are all about
these are recipes that we've already
built that you can just pick up and
start using you can just plug them into
your apps to make those intelligent
applications but say you're cooking with
a little twist
now it's gluten-free vegan pizza well
you still don't need to stand you still
don't need to start entirely from
scratch it's still pizza you can just
adjust what already exists out there and
so what we suggest for you here is try
cloud Auto ml sure maybe we haven't
trained our vision system on the
clothing type that your Kohl's customers
are wearing but no problem just feed in
your images with your labels into cloud
Auto ml and you'll be good to go
a small adjustment necessary now say
you're truly innovating you have your
own completely unique ingredients you're
doing something pretty different in the
kitchen I don't know maybe now you're
making an edible sock that tastes like
pizza
well machine learning and innovation are
in Google's core DNA in fact I can't
think of a single one of our consumer
products that doesn't have machine
learning in it somewhere
and so if you are innovating in the
kitchen if you're building truly new
recipes what we have for you is a cloud
machine learning engine this is access
to exactly the same infrastructure that
Google uses to train our models
incredible so you could if you wanted to
after the session grab a laptop open it
up and test drive our shiny gleaming
kitchen with all those appliances ready
to go you could feel the thrill of a
data center and all this cutting-edge
algorithms rising up to do your bidding
so solving business problems with
machine learning applied machine
learning is far easier than what most
people think but you don't realize is
that all those courses in university
those are all about how to build the
microwave not how to just use it to get
cooking and when I hear people say oh I
couldn't possibly get started with
machine learning until I take a course
in it or goodness a whole degree I can't
help but imagine that same person saying
I couldn't possibly use a microwave
until I've built one myself you can just
get cooking it's not the lack of degree
or course or knowledge that's holding
you back what's much much more important
than that what you need to get started
is creativity figure out what you're
gonna cook because all those tools are
already there waiting for you to use
them imagine gleaming kitchens just
waiting for you to come play in them but
since this is a thing labeler you need
to start by thinking what on earth do
you want labeled and see how creative
you can get with that you might imagine
the label being maybe the waveform that
sounds like a voice that could make a
hairdressers appointment for you or you
could imagine a few other cases like
maybe you are a loving son and you're
aging
parents sort vegetables by hand and you
want to save them the trouble of having
to do that on their farm so maybe you're
thinking about building a system that'll
label the vegetables and sort it
automatically so your parents don't have
to do it or maybe you're worried about
the ingredients that go into baby food
and you think it would be great if you
could automatically check whether the
ingredient is safe or spoiled before it
goes in or maybe you're into the idea of
a huge bank with trillions of dollars in
assets countering fraud and money
laundering automatically across millions
of accounts if you imagine that world
you imagined this world well these are
all real examples of things that have
been done on Google cloud platform the
first is a real family of cucumber
farmers the second is a Japanese
manufacturer of high-quality baby food
products cue pipe and the third is HSBC
who uses Google cloud to run a better
business and catch the bad guys across
27 million customers pretty different
chefs completely different applications
why is Google cloud platform the right
choice for all of them well think about
what you might want in a kitchen you'd
want good engineering so you probably
want to think about getting a partner
who's quality you trust but think more
long-term than that if you believe in
your own infinite creativity if you
believe in the future you would be crazy
to let yourself get locked into a
kitchen where the purveyor sets it up
one time for you and then controls which
you can and can't have in there and
every appliance is its own proprietary
little socket that you are not allowed
to tamper with and if your business
changes then you have to rebuild and
rewire the whole thing imagine instead
the
dream kitchen that becomes what you need
it to be instantly complete universal
wiring open interfaces the best of
everything all the modern appliances
always available and you can plug them
in with no fuss because that wiring is
universal that my friends is the power
of open source and that is what Google
and Red Hat together
believe in we don't want to see your
creativity squashed by what seemed like
a good idea yesterday
so we have built for you an incredible
future proof machine learning kitchen
this kitchen can expand contract as you
need it you can plug in whatever you
like all the most modern appliances are
there and compatible as you need them
fully customizable because none of us
can tell what innovations the future
will bring and we don't want you to have
to bet on the direction of progress and
lock yourselves in we want you to be
free to be as creative as all of us can
be together so I hope that you're
excited to dive in this machine learning
kitchen is there ready and waiting for
you to get started start playing in it
your machine learning adventure awaits
thanks so much
[Applause]